Istanbul remains a city of experiences.
One of the most memorable is enjoying a Turkish bath.
Today, baths welcome tourists and give a peek into a rich tradition.
You leave absolutely everything in the changing room.
Slip ungracefully into wooden slippers and shuffle into the steamy caldarium.
Turks brought the steam bath with them from Central Asia,...
...blended it with the Roman bath culture they found here...
...and created the Turkish bath.
First, you relax at the basin,...
...heat up, soften up under a cascade of hot water.
Savor the experience,...
...achieving maximum sweating and relaxation.
Then your attendant works you over,...
...scrubbing vigorously with rough Brillo pad-type mitts,...
...then sudsing and washing.
Refreshed and cleaner than you can remember ever being,...
...you venture back into the city, ready for more history and art.